was it sold as temporary oh this is here
to stay forever income tax is always
intended to be temporary
and then what happens is the government
goes hey look we've got all this money
we can do all these projects they kind
of like having all that money in that
power
so under a biden tax plan who wins who
loses i actually think everybody loses
somebody who is amassed a hundred
million dollars are well with biden's
tax laws
could potentially only transfer upon
death only 2 million of that 98 to their
heirs correct and 98 million would go to
the government
there was always a question whether a
tax was even legal until we got
the constitutional amendment out of all
the tax increases that we can have
capital gains certain write-offs
corporate taxes
which one hurts the economy the most
taxes on small business
hurts the economy the most when they say
that the rich don't pay a lot of tax
they kind of imply that it's because
they're cheating but what i find they
just have better tax advice
[Music]
my author today is an expert in taxes
but he looks at taxes in a very
different way that hopefully by the time
you're watching uh you're done watching
this interview you will also look at
taxes in a
incentive compensation structure type of
way it's fully qualified to speak on the
topic of taxes he was with ernst
young for many years also with pwc at
one point he was training thousands of
cpas
that were coming through ernst young at
the same time he was an adjunct
professor at masters
of tax program at arizona state
university for 14 years
and he wrote a book call tax free well
with that being said tom wheelwright
thank you so much for being a guest on
entertainment
thanks for having me patrick great to be
here so so there's a lot of things to
like why do you like the word tax why do
you like
learning about taxes tell us well you
know einstein said that the most
complicated
uh thing in the world to understand was
the tax law i'm going why not take on
the
most complicated area feinstein thought
it was hard and if
there was a way to make it simple for
people to understand and that sounds
like a
good thing to do so so unpack that for
me so because the way you explain taxes
is a lot more simpler than
sometimes others explain how do you view
taxes from your lens well
so i look at taxes as really what
most of the tax law is so there's 6 000
pages in the u.s tax law
roughly there's about 30 pages that
actually
give you the rates and how much tax to
pay there's one line that says all
income's taxable unless you say it isn't
unless we say it isn't
there's another line that says nothing's
deductible unless we say it is
okay so that's 30 pages there's another
5970 pages
and what is that well primarily it's
really incentives that the government
uses to encourage
people to undertake certain behaviors
whether it's
buying a home versus renting a home
whether it's sending your kids to
college
or whether it's starting a business
investing in energy
whatever it is so if you look at it as
this is really just an instruction guide
for reducing taxes and doing what the
government wants you to do
all of a sudden it completely changes
the picture
and your view and your outlook on taxes
so can can you
walk us back because one of the things i
got 50 pages of notes on taxes history
of taxes okay
so i i i'm enamored by the topic of
taxes because i look at taxes as if
you're in a company that pays you
commission and you see how the sales
commission is structured
and you have to figure out a way to
maximize the compensation structure of a
sales company
you're doing real estate you're with
keller williams you're with compass
you're with whoever
here's a comp structure you're with
insurance you're an advisor at morgan
you're selling pharmaceutical sales
there's a compensation structure
walk us through the history of taxes
i don't know how far back you can go but
specifically in the states
walk us through how taxes began why it
became you know
started and where we are today how much
more complex it is today versus what it
was
in 1913 when it first got started
so so remember in 1913 it was only a tax
on surplus income
it wasn't tax on all income it was
really a tax on what they called excess
earnings
and it really only applied to the very
wealthiest people
around 1944 they changed the law to
apply to employees but even then they
exempted
a living wage so basically the standard
deduction the personal exemptions
they were intended to exempt a living
wage
so that only the excess earnings again
were taxed
and then in the 1960s we started to see
some tax increases and we started to see
we started to see incentives you know we
had the 1954 act which was a major tax
act
um it was supposed to simplify it then
it complexified things
then we had the 1986 act which supposed
to simplify again
which is what it really did was broaden
the base
so it made more things taxable added
more complexity
what we have now is we actually have a
lower tax rate than we've had
in many many years in the u.s
at one point it was upwards of ninety
percent on the highest rates
and uh there's all sorts of shenanigans
going on to get out of those right
those kind of 90 taxes so right now you
know we're in that 40 percent range
which is
actually kind of a sweet spot for
governments they find that if people
are paying more than 40 percent they
have a huge incentive to get out of
taxes and if they pay
much less than 40 percent um the
difference between
a lot less than 40 and 40 percent
doesn't impact behavior a whole lot so
what the government really started doing
back in the early 60s with the
investment tax credit
was to kind of test the waters
and see what would happen if we gave
a tax incentive they finally realized
people hate paying taxes right
so if we give a little tax incentive
what will that change behavior
and what they found was yeah and in fact
it changes behavior
the right incentive will change behavior
in a massive way so really what taxes
have become
is a way for the government to leverage
government funds instead of the
government building houses
for example they encourage private
industry to build houses
and as a result um private industry does
10 times the work
for the same number of dollars because
they're getting rewarded through profits
and then when they make the profits
they're also paying the government so
the government wins
multiple times with these incentives so
so let's go back to the one topic that
always comes up is what's the big deal
with 40
do you know at one point the top
marginal tax rate in 1944 was 94
for any income about 200 000 which is in
today's correlation of
two and a half million dollars but then
i've read by a lot of different people
saying no one
ever actually paid 94 they just had it
there right and by the way if we look at
the 90
tax rate we stayed at
88 or higher from 1942
top marginal tax rate until 1963
it was minimum of 88 percent 48.49 we
dropped to 82
but then it went back up to 91 so
first of all if you can kind of walk us
through what does that mean 94
88 did anybody ever pay it how did
people get around it
what was the cause of raising it to that
level and why do we get away from it
well you know taxes are by definition
a burden right so they drag something
down
and what they found and it was actually
the great reagan experiment right
and actually started with uh john f
kennedy
john f kennedy was the first president
to really look at taxes as
what if we reduce taxes would that
stimulate the economy
uh what if we didn't have such a high
tax rate do we really need to have such
a high tax rate
and what he found was yeah i mean it
actually did stimulate the economy of
course reagan
i remember the reagan years very well
not just because i was there in
washington dc when that law was passed
but i remember when we had that
stagflation and we had height
we had high interest rates and we had
high taxes
and we had low economic production and
so what reagan did was he pretty much
went in and turned it on his head
and said look let's try a really low tax
rate let's get rid of all of these tax
shelters
which he did a pretty good job of let's
get rid of the tax shelters
that people were using to get out of
that 90 rate and instead let's just have
closer actually that was the closest
we've ever had to a flat tax
uh we only had two tax rates um uh after
the
1986 act right after the 1986 act so
all reagan was looking at was look we
think that we could
stimulate the economy you look at the
you know art laffer and the laffer curve
and supply side economics and that's
pretty much where we've been since then
uh going back to your question about 40
um
you know there's been a lot of studies
and my reading of the studies is 40
that magic number where you get much
over 40
and people really stop doing what you
want them to do
if you get much under 40 that that
difference below 40
and 40 percent doesn't have a huge
impact on the economy so
it seems to be some kind of a magic
number i i don't know why that is
but interestingly enough patrick it's
actually not just the us
that uses that 40 target it's most of
the world
so who screwed up the tax system from
1913 until today meaning which
which president abused and raised taxes
the most
that created a lot of different
opportunities for new tax funds to be
created
oh i don't i don't think any one
president could take credit for that
um there are there's there's a lot of
opportunities we're actually the
um we have the highest compliance rate
in the world you know we're at 85
percent
compliance rate which is really good
it's uh so i was in
italy uh with mr kiyosaki
and i was taught looking at the law in
italy you know they actually have
two levels of tax evaders they have the
little tax evader which kind of they
expect and you just get a slap on the
hand
and then they have a major tax evader
that you know goes to prison so forth
we don't get that okay you evade taxes
you go to prison if you avoid taxes
legally
you don't go to prison and so that's
really the key is just stay away from
cheating
what they're looking at right now is
cheaters and
uh the cheaters by the way are not all
the rich um that is the
completely false and if you look at the
data it's primarily the middle
middle income and it's a small business
where you get a lot of the cheating
oh so tell tell me more can you can you
elaborate on that so
for for example a small business i mean
how many times
uh patrick have you had a contract or
somebody say well if you pay me cash
i'll give you a discount plenty
right well that's just non-taxable
income they're not reporting that income
or you have a small business that
reports what we call a schedule
c in the us well schedule c is basically
a one-sided entry see we have double
entry bookkeeping
uh you know left side right side and the
idea is that they have to balance
right but in a schedule c a small
business
they only report one side of that
transaction well that makes it really
easy for them to fudge the numbers and
they find that a large proportion of the
cheating goes on in that small business
it's just easy to do and that's where
the irs does try to audit those but the
irs has been
hampered with uh with lack of qualified
professionals
so if i look at the numbers right now
history of it here's what it looks like
in 1931 our top marginal tax rate was 25
percent
if we go all the way back to 1913 it was
seven percent so from seven percent
by 1931 we're 25 world war one happens
we go up to 63 under fdr by the time fdr
is done he takes it all the way up to 94
percent
in 45 that's a top marginal tax rate
then comes truman
truman lowers it he's a democrat as well
uh
truman uh comes down and he takes it
down to 86 and a half percent
uh and then it goes all the way down
under truman it goes back up to 92. then
comes ike
ike 91 keeps it 91 the entire time
jfk takes it from 91 to 77 a democrat
ike being a republican
lbj goes from 77 stays at 77.
nixon takes it from 77 to 70. ford stays
70.
carter takes it from 70 to 69 reagan
takes it from 69
all the way down to 28 and then comes
everybody else so
many times when you talk about reagan
economics and the way he did his
taxes was very interesting he actually
raised corporate taxes slightly he
lowered you know he increased the bottom
line marginal to i think 15
and matched it with 2828 but what he did
you will hear a lot of people saying
this trickle-down economics doesn't work
trickle-down economics doesn't work
can you give the argument of the people
that say it doesn't work
what is their argument and what is the
argument for saying no it absolutely
worked
well of course the argument for people
say it doesn't work they're saying look
that's such a low rate
okay when you get to 28 that that the
difference between 28
and 50 say is not going to change
behavior substantially and so
you're not going to get a lot of bang
for your buck out of that
difference between 28 and 50. what
reagan did though
so on the flip side of this remember
what
the world looked like and particularly
the us economy looked like when reagan
came in
and he start by the way he started his
first tax bill was his first year in
office was 1981 it wasn't 1986
when we had the flattened flatting
flattening of the rates
he started with real estate he actually
brought uh gave
huge deductions incentives to real
estate in 1981
under the economic recovery tax act in
1981 right
and so in and what what reagan was
thinking was
look what if we bring it down
and we get rid of all the tax shelters
so there were
massive tax shelters uh you know cattle
shelters
real estate shelters all these other
shelters that were going on
prior to 1986 and so
you never paid 90 percent i mean there's
a famous case with jack
benny um the comedian who was able to
set up a corporation so that he paid
corporate rates instead of individual
rates of 90 percent
um so people were you know playing i
mean it was they were praying
playing fast and loose with the law
pretty well and it was pretty easy to do
prior to 86
and what reagan said was look what if we
tighten everything up so we actually are
going to broaden the base
so we're going to take away a lot of the
tax deductions a lot of the tax shelters
and instead say look you really are
going to pay tax you're going to pay 28
percent
you're you're not going to we're not
going to say it's 90 percent you pay 28
we're going to say it's 28 you pay 28
percent well what it did was
at the time is it takes all the
incentive out of doing something for tax
purposes
well actually what happened patrick is
the government doesn't actually like
not having that tool and so they started
raising the rates
almost immediately and started adding
back
in incentives okay that's pretty much
what happened
and the rate needed to get a little
higher in order to incentivize people
to reduce their taxes by investing in
real estate energy
etc and so you know the government
actually has been tweaking this
a long time and they really just found
i i think what they tried to do is tweak
it to a point where
it's both fair on the one hand so
but it doesn't it doesn't inhibit the
economy but it gives them some tools
to do what they want to do got it
interesting you explain it the way it
did uh you know
back in the days one of the biggest
things that the government convinced the
people to agree on
is to withhold taxes before they get the
money right
so it was almost like before you'd get
your money and then you would pay the
tax you would get if you made four grand
this month
you'd make four grand this month so they
were able to get the people to agree
no we're only going to pay you 2800 we
will withhold the 1200
so you are okay with that because you
won't really see the twelve hundred
dollars being kept by the government
how how would they i mean that's gotta
be one of the biggest sales of all time
to convince them to do that
how do you convince the populace to say
don't worry about it take 30
of my income before i even see it well
you you can't even even go one
one better than that patrick i mean
consider um what happened in
2017 when uh when trump
reduced the tax rates everybody almost
everybody got a tax cut
and yet the democrats were able to say
this is a bad deal why did that happen
it really was because what trump did at
the same time was reduce the withholding
rates
and so people didn't get as big a refund
they were pissed
they were upset with with trump because
they didn't get as big a refund even
though their
check was bigger what they really wanted
was the refund because they counted on
that for vacations
that was a savings people do not like
having to pay taxes on april 15th let me
tell you they would much rather get a
refund
i don't i don't know what it is about
our psyche but that seems to be the way
it goes
but do you know how to sell was made
like do you know the history of how they
were able to convince the power
you don't know that okay 1939 another
interesting
statistic for you i'm curious to know
what you know about this one in 1939 in
america only four million people file
taxes
income taxes this is 39 and they collect
the government collected
900 million 900 million dollars this is
in 39
four years later they went from only
four million people filing taxes
to 41 million they went from raising
900 million dollars in taxes to 13
billion dollars
do you know kind of what happened during
that four-year period 39-43
well yeah we had we were we had a war is
what what was really going on and
and what they're trying to do is raise
taxes to pay for the war i mean that's
that that's what this was
but what happened was employees had
never been taxed prior to 1943-4444
employees had never been taxed and what
they really wanted
was they wanted the federal employees to
be taxed because they were government
employees they said look we're giving
you money we're going to take some back
in order to do that though
constitutionally they couldn't just
tax federal employees and so what they
did was they taxed everybody
and it it does i mean all of the money
is in middle income
that's where the money is and so that's
where they went for it
do you think it was i mean again you
this is your world it's not my world
this is why
we brought you on because i want to
learn from you was it sold as
temporary or was it so that this is here
to stay forever
oh for sure income tax is always
intended to be temporary
it's always it's a basically a war
profits tax i mean the
idea is that it's a tax to pay for wars
um every time there's been attacks i
mean even think about 1913 what what
what do we have i mean
we had world war one right so it was it
was a tax to pay for a war
world war ii it's a tax to pay for a war
right and then it was supposed to
actually go back
and go away i mean the idea was it'll be
temporary we'll start at 7 25
you know how it's getting higher but
this is just temporary and then what
happens is the government goes
hey look we've got all this money we can
do all these projects
and so they they kind of like having all
that money in that power i mean that's
that's just the way people are that's
insane to me to say hey guys listen
we're going through tough times right
now we got to figure out a way to
everybody take a cut and they're like
you know it'll happen the company let's
just say
you're running a mortgage company it's
2007. everyone's making money in
november the rates change you no more
you know no income no assets negam her
loan is going away and you sit there and
say guys
i hate to say to you i can't afford to
pay the salary and penny right now i
have one of two choices i had to have to
fire you i have to pay half your salary
for the next 12 months
i hope you guys are okay with that
because there's only this this is the
only thing i can do
people say you know what it's okay i'll
stick around i'll be patient but the
idea is 12 months later if there's
recovery i want to go back to my old
salary right
but in this case they said no we're
going to stay here
now that we've realized we can go from
taxing 4 million
to taxing 41 million and you're not
complaining about it
we ain't changing it we're going to keep
it this way and the populist obviously
accepted it
well and you're right the withholding
was a key to that okay
because uh it's a tax not seen
is not a tax in a lot you know when when
we look at it
it's the it's the sales tax that we see
on the bottom of our
of our um when we pay at a restaurant
that's what hurts right because we see
that tax number
but if we're not seeing it because it's
just taken out of our paycheck it's much
easier to get that by the general public
i mean obviously it worked out and uh
fast forward 80 years later we're not
saying nothing about it and we're just
constantly sending the money to them
and you know the government's got much
bigger than what it was before and it's
very hard to back down it's and it's not
a republican or democrat thing both of
them are spending a lot of money when it
comes down to it so
that's the one part about the budget
let's take a different angle right now
so
uh president biden's launched his tax
plan we've heard about it
everyone reads about it you know capital
gains is going to go from 20 to 39
sick so corporate tax is going to go
from 21 to 28. you know
top line marginal ordinary income is
going to go 39 six and i'm not counting
the additional obamacare which is the
three point you know two nine or
whatever the percentages
that you have to pay for what are your
thoughts about what's being
proposed and what do you think will get
done and will they be able to
retroactively take you back to one one
of 2021
uh all very very good questions patrick
um let's start with the capital gains
tax because i think that's the most
interesting one because it actually
doesn't raise revenue
even the liberal think tanks say look
this doesn't raise
revenue the government accounting office
says this doesn't raise revenue
and so and yet they want to raise uh
capital gains tax and it's almost like
it's a
uh you know we've got this big call to
tax the rich well
what i think what people miss is that
the rich pay all the taxes to begin with
right i mean they pay 80 of the taxes
the the taxes aren't
fifty percent of the public doesn't pay
tax hardly at all
right and the and the other fifty
percent is paying all of it and most of
that's being paid by the top
ten percent so uh i think a lot of it is
is show now the the challenge with the
capital gains tax of course
there's the capital gains tax during
life which is
bad enough i mean it's you know it
affects markets and there's a question
you know
can you do that and what will the impact
be
but the capital gains tax at death is
actually pretty serious because
uh you know there have been some
calculations that if you follow biden's
tax
proposals through uh somebody with a
hundred million dollar estate
could easily end up with two million
dollars his heirs end up with two
million dollars
but 98 million dollars is taken by the
government between the state tax
and uh capital gains tax so what we're
talking about
of a massive shift in policy
let me say that one more time because
the audience may have not paid attention
to what you just said
so somebody who's amassed a hundred
million dollars of wealth okay
with biden's tax laws they could
potentially only
transfer upon death only 2 million of
that 98 to their
heirs is that what you just said correct
and 98 million would go to the
government
if his tax laws pass if you follow it
exactly the way i mean these
calculations been run and not
not just by me if you follow all of his
proposals through uh you've got to
assume that somebody with a
you know if they have 100 million dollar
state they probably have it's probably a
business right
and they probably don't have any what we
call basis for that so when they sell
if they sold that business they'd pay
capital gains right now 100 million
dollars
but they'd also under what the
plain language is they'd also pay 45
estate tax plus you have state income
taxes
right you can't ignore state income
taxes you know when we you know the
biden talks about this increase in
corporate rates like
the federal rate is the only rate
corporations pay when that's
not that's far from the truth i mean
some states
charge uh a large portion of the taxes
so it do you mind if we do this together
i'm going to have my editors
show this so they understand i'm
tracking with you so i got 100 million
dollars i want to sell my business
how much of that hundred million do i
pay in 10 and i'm in california let's
just say
or new york because i see what you're
doing i'm in california i got 100
million dollar business i sell it
how much do i pay capital gains taxes
under biden's laws
so in in california just california
alone you're gonna pay 13.3 percent
okay so that's 13.3 million okay
uh uh biden you're going to pay
somewhere between uh 39.6 million
and depending on if you end up having to
pay the
obamacare tax that's another three point
eight percent well you can't avoid it so
if you're living in i'm
i'm paying a three-year-old you
literally could end up paying 43.4
percent
so okay let's stay together four percent
federal tax
so at this point you have me at 56.4
million is gone
i have 43.6 million left to my name
what else will i pay right but then
you've got a
understanding you've got a 45 you've got
okay so you have three and a half
million dollar exam so out of that
hundred million
three and a half million dollars isn't
subject to a state tax
but 96.5 million is subject to a 45
percent estate tax
so you take night 45 percent of 96.5
million
and add that to your number and i think
you come up with right of 198.
you you see if i'm close there i think
i'm pretty close
oh so i take 96 and a half million at
45 correct i get 43 million dollars
right add it to what you've got that
you're already paying
which is an additional 43 million so
that's 86 million
let's just say it's a 90 million bucks
right there no because
because you've got okay if you've got
you got 43 million
yeah and then you've already got 56
million yep
i paid 56 oh that's right so it's 90 i
got you now
so the 45 million plus the 56 million
that's
that's 99 million just so you know
well 43 okay 40 40
plus 50 is 90 right that's that's 99
million
53 right plus five
that's eight that's 98 million dollars
so there's your 98 million and all of
that what you just said
could realistically happen to somebody
it's possible you know hopefully senior
minds will prevail but
but you know if you just look at it on
this black and white
you know hopefully you're not paying the
state tax on top of income tax you
shouldn't have to
but that's what i mean that's that's
kind of what the proposal looks like
so it uh it's pretty much a confiscation
of your assets when you die
so under a biden tax plan who wins who
loses
uh i i actually think everybody loses
tell me don't think there are any
winners because
um if if you take away
if you take away the incentives do you
still
get for example do you still get the
technology
that that we're creating do you still
get the businesses um business owners
you know we're business owners right and
business owners take a lot of risk okay
are you are you gonna take that risk if
um
you can't leave anything to your kids uh
uh what happens to family farms what
happens to family businesses
you never have a second generation
business um
do i mean do you think the average
person is going to be happy
when their neighborhood uh a restaurant
goes under
because the government confiscated it um
i'll tell you who the big winners are
actually
um the big winners are big corporations
corporate america
they are the biggest winners under this
plan because what happens is
if you had let's say that you've got a
small business
it's worth 10 million dollars but you
get a
four a five million dollar capital gains
tax at death
okay you get a five million dollar
capital gains tax at death
a 10 million dollar business cannot pay
that
they don't have money so what do they
have to do they have to sell it but it's
a distress sale
because it's a fire sale who are they
gonna sell it to will the people with
the money who has the money
big corporate america so i actually
believe patrick that the big
winners out of all of these tax plans is
corporate america
okay so let me be a skeptic here and and
i'm gonna go to conspiracy town for uh
for a second here with
let's see if there's anything that you
say awesome so uh uh
i'm at a program in boston with 144
other entrepreneurs from around the
world 64 different countries and we're
all learning about different laws and
how it's played
in many different countries it's very
open how to manipulate the market by
buying politicians out it was very open
when one guy's from brazil
said look pay the guy half a million
dollars who needs to be reelected
if you're going to make 10 million on
this what's a half a million dollar just
pay to the guy let him come out with a
new law
to make it higher to compete in the
marketplace so
how much is that is happening in the u.s
where guys are saying
look a biden or this camp you win
great i'll give up a little bit of taxes
here and i'll be wink wink yeah we
should raise taxes
but behind closed doors i want you to
eliminate 80 of my competition
and i'll buy them at distressed sales
and rather than paying
a hundred dollars you know 100 pennies
on a dollar i'll pay
50 cents on a dollar and i'm saving 50
cents
who cares if i'm paying 10 more in taxes
i'm still netting 40 more
how much of those conversations actually
takes place
and how much of it is just conspiracy
skepticism that'll never happen
uh i i'm i actually think i'm sure it
takes place
okay i don't think it may not be the
primary driver
but just look at what's happened during
the pandemic
who won and who lost small business got
crushed
big business made out like bandits
massive okay
so so now now fast forward now you're
talking about new tax laws right
and and they're talking about raising
the corporate rate from 21
to 28 well it was 35 three years ago
okay and so you're raising distill
only half as you only half the way back
to where you were
and then there's pushback well maybe we
could take 25
but boy that would be really tough to be
competitive even at 25
because we've got state rates in
in exchange we get to buy out
all of these small business at fire sale
prices
i think that's a pretty good trade-off
frankly i'm if i were a big business
let me give you one more so one of the
proposals of biden
is to eliminate the like-kind exchange
on real estate
right somehow this is some big loophole
it's obviously not a loophole it's a
code section
so here's what happens so they
eliminated on real estate which by the
way
only affects middle america i mean the
big guys don't use
1031 exchanges they don't do that anyway
okay so
that's who it's affecting okay but
remember who still gets it then
who gets a like-kind exchange that's a
non-taxable exchange
anytime a business acquires
another business in exchange for stock
that is a
tax-free exchange it is exactly the same
as a 1031 like-time exchange but they're
not even
talking about getting rid of the tax uh
the tax benefits of mergers and
acquisitions they're only talking about
getting the tax
rate of the tax benefits of real estate
who does that hurt well that hurts the
family farms
it usually hurts the family hot farms
hurts a small business
um who's owns their you know they own
their own building they're they're
wanting to sell their
their building that they what they want
to do is they really want to trade into
let's say a triple net lease on a
walgreens
something like that and have a nice you
know
reasonable income for their retirement
right this is we're talking about
retirement assets
of entrepreneurs that's what we're
talking about and what you're talking
about is
let's you know the entrepreneurs they
don't really need retirement assets
what we really need is we need the big
corporate america
to uh actually own those companies and
be able to take them over
so the seriously this these are
conversations i'm having with clients
right now patrick
is that if this capital gain if this
goes through
then it will completely change the way a
small business
exits the small business owner exits
their business because
no longer will they be able to just sell
it for cash and pay a small capital
gains rate
instead what they're going to have to do
is they're going to have to sell to a
big business
because the only way they can that the
primary way to avoid that
big capital gains rate because remember
they're only getting that they're only
over a million dollars
once in their lifetime and it's when
they sell their business right it it
so so the the capital gains on business
is a little like patrick if
when the day you retired your entire
401k plan was
taxable that it's it's the same
it's the same effect right you didn't
get taxed when you took it out
you get taxed the day you retire well
the same is
now that's what they're proposing for
business owners so what happens is
instead businesses are either going to
have to aggregate and become big
or they're going to have to sell out to
a big business those are really the two
choices that they're left with
out of all the tax uh increases that we
can have right ordinary income okay fine
capital gains fine real estate
we got certain write-offs that we got
going on we got corporate taxes
which one hurts the economy the most
when we raise it
oh i i think the taxes on small business
hurts the economy the most um the
capital gains tax
probably has the least beneficial um
it has the least benefit because what it
does is remember also
that uh you know capital gains tax will
definitely have a
downward um effect on the market right
downward pressure on the market
because people won't want to sell um to
hold on to it longer
people won't be buying as much and so
what happens is is that that hurts the
401ks
okay and it's it's average americans who
own 401ks it's it's not the big guys
doing 401ks
you know you're not finding um uh rich
people
with lots of money for them guys outside
of maybe mitt romney
and so what happens is is that the
capital gains tax
doesn't raise much money but it does
hurt a lot of people so
i actually think from a policy
standpoint that's one of the
to me that that plus the um capital
gains of death
that whole capital gains scenario is to
me
probably the the worst part of this uh
the corporate rate they can raise that
25 percent i don't think that hurts a
lot
i think uh um you know the the
international rules they've got to be
really careful with because that could
have a huge impact that was probably the
best thing by the way that came out of
the 2017 act
was the international the corporate
international rules those were actually
can you go deeper on that unpack that
yeah so uh you know we had this uh
before 2017 we had these corporate
inversions this is where
uh apple for example they did this right
they
they have a small uh company in
ireland which has a 12 tax rate uh
basically acquires apple it's kind of a
a mental swallowing the whale type of
thing and now
we have uh we have all these earnings
that are in
outside of the u.s well apple can't
bring them back in because they bring
them back in they pay 35
right they've got to leave them outside
the u.s well what the
what what what the the the fitty rules
did
was allow you to have this intellectual
these earnings from intellectual
property at roughly 13 and a half
percent
okay so now we've had
by what i've seen uh the calculations
i've seen about 1.6 trillion dollars
brought back into the u.s as a result
of the changes in in these rules well so
let's say you push
you get rid of those rules uh biden's
talking about a 28
tax rate not a 13 tax rate well now what
do you do well unless you can
you know in la la land you can have a
worldwide minimum tax but that is purely
lala land okay that is
never going to happen because why would
ireland agree to that
and you have to get a hundred percent
agreement
it's never going to happen so if you had
a minimum tax
it may work but without a minimum tax
what are you going to do you're just
going to go back to this corporate
inversion people just
they'll just leave the money offshore
they can do that it's just not that hard
i mean tax planning is
when it comes down to once you
understand the rules
it's just not that hard patrick so um
you know i
that's actually frankly what i liked
best about the 2017 act i like the
reduction in the corporate rate
and i liked the um the international
rules that fitted the guilty stuff even
though they're very complex
they're i think they're a really good
start in the right direction
to to really encourage investment in the
u.s what i would have liked to have seen
was rather than the democrats arguing
about well we need to
undo this 21 corporate tax rate is that
i wish they said we need to be at 15
because that would then make the u.s a
tax haven now
everybody wants to be here okay and
instead of punishing u.s companies
right and punishing people for locating
the us which they are
now remember also we don't have a
value-added tax
so you know you take a take take an
example if i can
boeing sends an airplane to france
okay not only do they pay corporate
income tax in france but there's a
value-added tax
okay 22 right but
but but think about this okay but airbus
sends a plane to the us there's no value
out of tax
there's just a corporate tax why don't
we why don't we have a value-added tax
because we have sales taxes and we've
we've never
gone that next step to a federal level
uh this is what really uh people like
ted cruz have been arguing for is a flat
tax right which is really a
value-added tax i mean that's what a
flat tax would be it's a national sales
tax
the concern of course is a value-add tax
is an
absolute fabulous idea as long as you
don't
also have a high income tax but the
challenge is
that you know once you get a tax as you
were just
talking right so you were just saying
once you start that tax
it never it never goes away i mean it's
permanent i mean if we're going to tax
it that's why we don't have one
why don't we tax other countries that
want to do business with us rather than
taxing
we're getting taxed when we're doing
business with others but we're not
taxing them when they're doing business
with us and this is where the money's at
well i'll tell you that that's actually
the idea behind tariffs right i mean
tariffs are the alternative yep to the
value added tax that's
trump had a lot of that tariffs on china
that's what tariffs are for
is to compensate it's really that that
the opposite of the value-added tax we
don't have valuab tax we have terrorists
and so when they when the other
countries had tariffs they're adding
tariffs on top of their value-added tax
so it's still an it's still not an even
um it's not an even plan for the longest
time i mean that's how the the country
ran
based on excise tax and uh tariffs that
we had that's that's kind of how
a lot of the money was made by the way
interesting fact when we're talking
about the war how they raised
you know from four million people doing
taxes to 41 million and they raised from
900 million to what 13 billion dollars a
number i read you
back when uh uh lincoln was president in
1862 they passed the tax
uh for it was the first income tax they
passed in 1862
no one paid it only the well-off the
rich people paid it by the end of civil
war only 10
paid the income tax it started in 1862
by 1873 it went away meaning hey
we collected money 11 years we paid off
the civil war not go back and don't pay
any taxes
they did it the right way then but now
it's kind of like no no no keep paying
it keep paying it keep paying it
what happened what happened was patrick
we got constitutional amendment
that's what happened so really there was
always a question whether a tax was even
legal
until we got the um constitutional
amendment right
back in 1913. so taxes had to go away
they could only be done for certain
short periods of time with the
constitutional amendment that brought on
the irs
and it made it permanent um
going back to you saying you're talking
to your clients what are some of the
common questions you hear your clients
asking right now
oh they're they're you know a lot of
their question is okay what am i going
to do
tags in my business what am i going to
do from an estate planning standpoint
you know how do i how do i make sure
that all my money doesn't go to the
government
what am i going to do about these
capital gains no here's an interesting
one so nobody's
nobody's complaining about the raising
the corporate tax rate nobody's
really nobody's complaining about the uh
race to 39.6 percent the top rate from
37 to 39.6 percent
nobody's talking about that they don't
like the
1031 like ken exchanges going away
that's you know that's going to put a
damper on the real estate market for
sure
um you know that's that that takes
liquidity out of the market is what it
does
you know these capital gains and 1031 is
really a capital gains tax right that's
what it is
so what you're doing is you just take
liquidity out of the market
and nobody that's in the market wants to
lose liquidity in the market
that's what makes the market work is
liquidity and so
i i think that the capital gains tax is
the one that's probably the most
problematic
the reality is uh patrick you could go
back to a 70
or 75 percent tax rate over 10 20
30 40 50 million dollars nobody would
bad and i
they wouldn't even bad and i um nobody's
going to complain
uh is are there going to be fancy ways
to to deal with that yeah of course you
got the money
if if you got that high of a tax rate
you're going to play the games
legally to make sure that you don't pay
that high tax rate just like you were
saying uh like when jack benny
uh did back in the um back in
the early days so um this is
this is where we are right now and it's
just really interesting
to see it'll be really interesting to
see what actually
uh transparent and see if we get some
cooler heads in there to say you know
what we don't really want to confiscate
uh business owners uh retirement i think
by the end of the year it's a very
likelihood that in 2022
man of the year could be joe manchin i
think man of the year in 2022 could be
joe manchin because
he has more control than kamala harris
he has more influence than kamala harris
he's probably the most influential
politician right now
in america because he's not willing to
compromise
certain values on helping advance the
economy and you have to respect the guy
where he's at
but you're talking to your clients your
client asks you
hey tom man what do i do do i sell my
business
do i what recommendation are you given
are you saying
sell this year rather than next year are
you saying
look are you keeping it for five ten
years who cares hang on to it
if you know what kind of feedback are
you giving to i know obviously you can't
give a blanket advice to everybody
but what are some of the feedback you're
giving to your clients no
look once you understand the tax law you
realize that there are a lot of
different options
there are a lot of different ways to go
and and you know my job for example is
to
help you do what you want to do and not
pay tax that's my job
and so we there there are ways there are
always going to be ways to deal with
this
okay we can deal with the capital gains
tax now what i am telling every client
is
do your estate planning now you asked
the question patrick earlier
could they go back to the beginning of
the year that is
really horrible horrible policy
okay could they do it maybe i don't know
i mean i i'm i'm not sure that that's
legal to go back
could they go back to today yeah i mean
if you look at this 2017 act
um that's that was retroactive to
september
right september 27th is when those
provisions were retroactive most of them
were retroactive to september 27th
well that's when the legislation was
first proposed and so
that's not unusual uh now we don't yet
have legislation actually proposed we
just have guidance ideas we don't have
actual legislation yet
so what we're hopeful at that we have
this small window of opportunity
right now to do some good estate and
income tax planning and they always go
together by the way you never do a state
plan without doing income tax planning
you have to do them together
um but if you do that right now there's
at least
a hope that uh you're gonna you're gonna
be within the window
if you don't do it now and you wait till
the end of the year
and it passes then you know you know
you're going to be stuck
states a lot of people are looking into
moving to different states
okay a lot of people when i met with
arthur laffer in tennessee i said why
are you in tennessee you said it's the
lowest all-in taxes in all of america
and he's not from nashville tennessee
you move this practice to nashville
tennessee
what are some states that are winning
right now what are some states that
uh people ought to consider and what are
some deciding factors on somebody to sit
there and said i should look at this
state that state and this state
well um first of all look at all the
taxes don't just look at income tax
okay because every state has to have
money
and they just get it different ways
whether it's sales tax or property tax
income tax those are pretty much the
three legs of the stool right the income
stool for a state
texas obviously is winning florida is
winning those are the two big
winners right now
south dakota should be winning right um
it doesn't have a tax
and like say tennessee has a uh they
have a
actually they have a low personal income
tax but they actually have a pretty high
uh business income tax so it's uh
tennessee's
probably would not be my first choice i
would probably choose with texas
um and texas is even better than florida
because florida does have a corporate
income tax they just don't have a
personal income tax uh wyoming nevada
no income taxes so i think those are
kind of the
the winners of course you have to look
at you know where do you want to live
uh i think that's more important uh
texas does raise a lot of their revenue
from property tax so you have to look at
okay
what are my property tax going to look
like and do i
do i even care right um but it is those
states with low income tax or no income
tax
that are really the big winners right
now i mean even even like
i mean take um i'm in arizona
and the surrounding states not arizona
itself because we just
increased our taxes by 80 it's just
lovely what we did
um so now what we have is we have utah
new mexico colorado all with
much lower tax rates in arizona so i
don't think arizona is going to be the
big growth state if
this prop 208 um uh stands up
in court if it stands up in court then i
i think that we're going to go the way
of california
um i think the west coast and the east
coast uh outside of
uh again florida i think they're pretty
much toast
um people are just going to keep moving
out unless they want to pay the high
what i call a beach tax that to
you know to live in those states but um
the middle america
i think is winning they're winning with
um you know they're winning they
they've won throughout the pandemic
frankly is that they've got lower tax
rates
they they are more conservative
governments and uh
and people are moving there in the
droves first time in 172 years
california's population
didn't grow that's pretty insane to be
thinking about that first time in 127
years
172 years well and and and what did they
do they they suggest we ought to have a
16.9 percent tax
that's that's so why are you still in
arizona why are you still in arizona
oh i'm hopeful that the supreme court uh
turns down prop 208
and it will be okay so so there's
there's a couple things that people
and this will be the last thing i want
to address before we wrap up is there's
a couple things
with piano will wrap up with your book
there's a couple things that you'll hear
about
so here's oh look million dollar homes
in california are selling like hot cakes
that our article came out from cnbc
today record-breaking the average home
stays on the market for eight days
before selling right now that's
insane we put our house on the market 24
hours two offers done cash deals it was
sold
i i and two years prior to that i put in
the market one year i can sell it
i put in the market uh six months ago it
just goes away within a couple days
so people who are in money making years
of their lives
versus people who have made the money in
their lives which means
i'm 62 years old i'm sitting on 17
million dollars of money i've
accumulated
some of it stocks some of it's bonds
some of it's real estate some of it's
artifacts collections
cards whatever you want to call it i got
17 million bucks
i'll move to california i don't care
about what's going to happen i don't
need to accumulate wealth anymore i've
already sold my little business
small business that i had et cetera et
cetera what is the different mindset on
how somebody should be thinking about if
they're in the prime money
making years of their lives versus
somebody who's already made their
money what would you say to both of
those audiences well i'll tell you my
clients i mean i just had a note from a
client this morning
and he is moving to florida from
california why
taxes pure and simple um i've uh
my my wife's also a cpa she has a cpa
firm
she has clients who moved from arizona
to texas once prop 208 passed uh to
think that people don't
react to tax increases is uh
pretty crazy um but because people do so
if you're
you know if you're earning a lot of
money or you're about to
how about you're about to sell your
business get it
get out of dodge okay let's figure out a
way to do that in such a way that you
don't pay high taxes and lose half of
your wealth
um to the government because there are
ways to do it so it's it's not just what
state you're in but it's also
uh you the team you have around you you
know what advisors from ta
you know tax advisors accountants
lawyers so forth
i mean when they say that the rich don't
pay a lot of tax um
you know they kind of imply that it's
because they're cheating but what i find
is is that they just have better tax
advice
i mean that's all it is and they're
really doing things that government
incentivizes to do they do things
government wants you to do
and so uh they pay less tax um i don't
think i have a big problem with that
what should i be thinking about when
considering hiring an accountant like
i've gone through good bad
ugly and great what what would you
recommend
you're one you've been in it you've
trained many you've been around the
block for a while
what should somebody consider because
i've been part of a regional guy that's
a smaller guy
and then when he came down to trouble he
bailed that he's like oh you know what
it's just oh i'm so busy i'm like what
then i want gone to the bigger ones
cohen resnick pwc
kpmg bkd all these other guys and if one
guy decides to change careers at least
the company still holds the
takes care of you as a client and stays
with them but from your perspective
what is the ideal criteria as one should
look for for hiring an accountant
yeah i've i've been with the big guys
you know as you said and i've been with
the
and i've had my own firms for 25 years
so
um i what i what i always look for is
are they looking at at this from a
transaction standpoint or from a
relationship standpoint because
if you're just saying a transaction
standpoint you're really going to be
very limited
in what you can do in a single
transaction
for example somebody comes to you says
uh okay i've got this i
i've got these new mugs here are they
deductible
and it's the wrong question the question
should be how do i make that mug
deductible okay how do i do what i want
to do
and pay less tax not how do i pay less
tax
so what we look at for example what i
teach people
my cpas we have a network of cpas
what i teach them is look at the whole
picture look at the estate plan look at
legacy look at the income tax plan look
at what they
that what do you want to do you know
where are you in your life
you you mentioned it are you in the high
earning years are
have you made your money do you want to
even leave money to your kids i mean my
mother just wanted to break even she
didn't want to leave us any money so she
was fine just spending that well if
that's what you want to do you don't
have an estate tax issue do you
so you know looking at that personal all
the personal aspects
and what you really want to do i mean
that's the question how do you tell that
part but how do you tell a part of cpa
like
you can't really find that out in day
one you almost have to go in bed so
what is the process of saying dude is
this a good guy
bad guy do i go through referrals what
are five
questions i should ask the cpa when i'm
hiring them
what should that relationship look like
well i do actually go through that in my
book
tax free wealth so chapter 23 is all
about finding the right tax advisor
perfect um
but nevertheless i actually think it's
more important the questions that they
ask you then the questions
than the answers they give you so i
think it's far less important
where if you're asking questions the
problem is
you don't know what the answers are so
they could pull the wool over i mean
you're not going to know whether they're
right or not what your advisor is for
it's like when you go to a doctor and
you spend 15 minutes talking to the
doctor
the doctor is spending 14 minutes asking
you questions
to get to get a good evaluation of what
they should do and then they give you
one minute
of advice right take this do this do
this
one minute out of 15. that's what your
advisor should do whether their tax
advisor legal
advisor or health advisor is they ought
to be asking you the questions
rather than expecting you to ask
questions and give you answers
that would be asking you the questions
so that they can delve into that we
spend most of our time asking questions
not giving answers phenomenal feedback
right there so since you brought up
tax-free wealth
to finish up with your book here a few
things a quick summary from your book in
the book you talk about the fact that
tax laws was written as a set of
incentives a way the government
encourages certain activities that
benefit the economy
and promote social policy you talked
about that earlier vast majority of tax
code is not written to raise money but
to stimulate growth
it's not about what you make but what
you take home at the end of the day
everything you do either increases or
lowers your taxes
tax planning is not an end of the year
activity but a daily one
tell us a little bit on what we should
expect from your book
well first of all it's really easy i
mean i best uh
uh best review i ever got was that it
was a great beach read
um um one person said that another
person said it read like a spy novel so
those were those are my two favorite
reviews uh
it's very it's it's not meant for this
it's not meant for a tax advisor okay it
is meant for
the average person and it's written for
the average person
it's uh basically uh a lot of stories
and a lot of explanation about how it
really works
in very simple terms what you really i'd
expect is a completely different way of
looking at taxes
um i i think taxes i think the tax law
can be very positive
from the standpoint that really it's not
just a roadmap for reducing taxes
but it's actually a roadmap for building
wealth
just take a business deduction a
business
a business expense is only deductible if
it has a business purpose
it's ordinary it's necessary and it's
documented
if we only as business owners only spent
money
that had a business purpose was ordinary
necessary and was documented we'd make a
lot more money
so i look at the tax law as a great
instruction guide to building wealth
it's not just an instruction guide for
reducing taxes
but they go hand in hand you make way
more money when you pay a lot less tax
i like it makes a lot of sense we're
going to put the link to the book bro
below tom thank you so much for being
against somebody taming
thank you patrick pleasure taxes boring
but very important matter of fact if you
stuck around till the very end just
comment below and say pat i watched the
whole thing
maybe even send me a tweet because most
people don't finish tax videos
i'm proud of you because this is
actually very important to learn about
taxes
if you enjoyed today's video you want to
go a little bit deeper i did a video
reacting to biden's
proposed tax plan just about four weeks
ago if you've never seen it click over
here
and if you missed my interview with
arthur laffer which was four or five
years ago
click over here take care everybody bye
you